[SPEAKER_01]: Okay, so you go back to the... Yeah, and I'm moving and I'm looking for either like wet feet, like any kind of marks where if he climbed up the wall, got back into the bridge.
[SPEAKER_00]: So you look for Fairfield as you walk back up the path that you've come.
[SPEAKER_00]: All right.
[SPEAKER_00]: Morning of the Third of Wealsun, Jude goes back up the path towards basically the castle.
[SPEAKER_00]: All right, so you travel back to the stairway.
[SPEAKER_01]: And nobody had hit the water before a certain point.
[SPEAKER_01]: So as I backtrack, if I see dripping water on the floor, I'll know that was him.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_00]: Along the path, you find no dripping water.
[SPEAKER_00]: Nothing like that.
[SPEAKER_00]: You make your way back to where the stair is.
[SPEAKER_00]: What do you want to do?
[SPEAKER_01]: Uh, start searching the lower levels, uh, looking for- The lower levels?
[SPEAKER_01]: Well, by the lower levels I just mean like, um, I don't want to go up if I don't have to.
[SPEAKER_01]: I want to see where like- So there's that- He said like there was barracks.
[SPEAKER_01]: I know where the armory was.
[SPEAKER_00]: Well, well, no, no, no.
[SPEAKER_00]: There was that one room that takes the stairs up to the inner sanctum.
[SPEAKER_00]: And that's where we were where we- And that's where when you fought the, um,
[SPEAKER_00]: The Toli is where you were.
[SPEAKER_00]: That was the inner sanctum.
[SPEAKER_01]: Was there only one route?
[SPEAKER_01]: There was no offshoots?
[SPEAKER_00]: No offshoots.
[SPEAKER_01]: Then I'll go ahead and go back up.
[SPEAKER_00]: And then you go up to the top of that and that's where the inner sanctum is and the door is barred there.
[SPEAKER_00]: So nobody can come in or out.
[SPEAKER_01]: The door is barred?
[SPEAKER_00]: When you guys went into the inner sanctum, you barred that door.
[SPEAKER_01]: Well, but we would have barred it from the inside, right?
[SPEAKER_00]: That's what I'm saying.
[SPEAKER_00]: What I'm trying to say is...
[SPEAKER_00]: The inner sanctum, where you are, was barred off when you left it.
[SPEAKER_00]: So you can walk all the way up the stairs and get to that area.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay, so I do that.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay, you go up there.
[SPEAKER_01]: And nobody's banging on the door to try to get in or anything like that?
[SPEAKER_00]: Well, you come up there and you don't hear anybody banging on the door.
[SPEAKER_00]: There's the dead body of the hobgoblin there that you had left.
[SPEAKER_00]: Right.
[SPEAKER_00]: Everything was as it was.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_01]: The dead Toli guy?
[SPEAKER_00]: You go in and check?
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_00]: He's there too.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_01]: No wet soaking footprints anywhere around?
[SPEAKER_00]: Nothing like that.
[SPEAKER_01]: I listen where we barred the door and I'll unbar it and go through.
[SPEAKER_00]: So you want to look out there?
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_00]: Hobgoblins all over that place.
[SPEAKER_01]: Like, all over what place?
[SPEAKER_00]: So, here's the door to the Inner Sanctum, and there's a little hallway, and this is the place, basically, that goes to the armory, that goes to the barracks.
[SPEAKER_00]: They're hobgoblins.
[SPEAKER_01]: Oh, the ones that we snuck by?
[SPEAKER_01]: Exactly.
[SPEAKER_01]: That's right.
[SPEAKER_01]: They're all there, and you see them all there, and then one of them... No, I close it and bar it.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_01]: I don't make eye contact.
[SPEAKER_01]: I just be like... Because remember, I'm invisible, so I just...
[SPEAKER_01]: Close it.
[SPEAKER_01]: No wet footprints anywhere.
[SPEAKER_00]: You see no wet footprints?
[SPEAKER_00]: No.
[SPEAKER_00]: Fucker.
[SPEAKER_01]: He's either still down below or he swam his way out, which could mean he's on the ship with Kane Toli or he's talking to his troops on the outside.
[SPEAKER_01]: Hmm.
[SPEAKER_01]: Any other way.
[SPEAKER_01]: I checked that big area.
[SPEAKER_01]: There's no private staterooms, no other rooms that we didn't explore.
[SPEAKER_00]: No, one side is basically a records station, a library, the other room is a council room.
[SPEAKER_00]: Those are the only two areas that there are, besides the stairs that go down.
[SPEAKER_00]: And you don't see any other exits or entrances.
[SPEAKER_00]: This truly is closed off from the rest of the keep.
[SPEAKER_01]: Right, like basically from kind of like the lord of the keeps.
[SPEAKER_01]: It was the only way to get down.
[SPEAKER_01]: Exactly.
[SPEAKER_00]: Looking out the window in the inner sanctum where the council room is, you can actually look out over the island, right?
[SPEAKER_00]: And the army that had attacked the night before, they're not attacking anymore.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_00]: So, you know, they did their diversion.
[SPEAKER_01]: It was done.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah, right.
[SPEAKER_01]: Who said don't waste guys.
[SPEAKER_00]: In the other area where the library is, you actually can see that
[SPEAKER_01]: The ship, the Seaghost.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah, the Seaghost.
[SPEAKER_01]: It's gone.
[SPEAKER_01]: Would he have had time in 30?
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah, he would have had time in 30 minutes while we were moving the barrels to swim out from the cove.
[SPEAKER_01]: Can I gauge to get to the Seaghost?
[SPEAKER_01]: He could have done it.
[SPEAKER_00]: There would have been sharks, but I mean, after the barrel, totally.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah, right.
[SPEAKER_01]: Especially after the barrel, right?
[SPEAKER_01]: They would have all jetted.
[SPEAKER_01]: So if the sea ghost is gone... Alright.
[SPEAKER_01]: Anything cool in the library?
[SPEAKER_00]: Histories, nothing magical.
[SPEAKER_00]: I think there's some interesting stuff.
[SPEAKER_01]: Anything on Suley's ship?
[SPEAKER_00]: On Sule's stuff?
[SPEAKER_00]: Not really.
[SPEAKER_00]: Most of this stuff is kind of like maps, almanacs, trade routes.
[SPEAKER_00]: Any recipes for the mix?
[SPEAKER_00]: No.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay, that's super secret.
[SPEAKER_01]: Alright, I leave it barricaded and I guess I work my way back.
[SPEAKER_01]: So, unless the, since there's no threat, unless for some reason the hobgoblins think that they need to break in on the inner sanctum, so to speak,
[SPEAKER_01]: Unless they decide to beat that door down, then there's no way that people can come down back at us, right?
[SPEAKER_01]: No.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_01]: On my way back, I just double check, make sure that there's no, you know, water on the floor leading to a secret spot in the wall, shit like that.
[SPEAKER_01]: Sure.
[SPEAKER_00]: The only place you really don't know is that, and this is right where the party is, that side tunnel.
[SPEAKER_00]: With the bars that goes into the big area, the caverns, that Gouge looked at but hasn't gone to explore.
[SPEAKER_01]: Can I check that?
[SPEAKER_01]: Is that locked?
[SPEAKER_00]: The gate's open, but I mean, if you want to, you can check right in with the guys there first, because they're right there.
[SPEAKER_01]: But if I talk to them, will I break my invisibility?
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_01]: Because I only get that now.
[SPEAKER_01]: So I'm going to check that out.
[SPEAKER_01]: If it's locked, then I can't.
[SPEAKER_01]: If it is unlocked, then I'll check it.
[SPEAKER_01]: It's unlocked.
[SPEAKER_00]: You go through it and basically there are a lot of caverns back here.
[SPEAKER_00]: And what you notice is back in this area there are these racks
[SPEAKER_00]: Obviously where the barrels were.
[SPEAKER_01]: Oh, like a lot more of the barrels, yeah.
[SPEAKER_00]: Or they were.
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_00]: Because the truth is, it seems like there would be tens of thousands of barrels that could be stored here.
[SPEAKER_00]: Right.
[SPEAKER_00]: Right?
[SPEAKER_00]: So obviously this warehouse, you don't know what it was filled like beforehand.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay, no wet footprints on the floor.
[SPEAKER_00]: No wet footprints on the floor at all.
[SPEAKER_00]: However, after going through this area, which is a large area, you do find another tunnel that leads to
[SPEAKER_00]: Another bar door, like the place before, that is closed and locked.
[SPEAKER_00]: Like I can't get through it?
[SPEAKER_00]: Exactly.
[SPEAKER_00]: It's got a key, but it looks out onto a little cove and you can see the outside.
[SPEAKER_00]: The sun is up by now.
[SPEAKER_00]: The beach.
[SPEAKER_00]: A little cove right now.
[SPEAKER_01]: Can I see any footprints in the sand since the sun is up?
[SPEAKER_00]: Like since I can see the cove?
[SPEAKER_00]: If there's a little grill or a little opening.
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah, actually you do see some footprints on the sand, but that's it.
[SPEAKER_00]: But like, okay.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_01]: All right.
[SPEAKER_00]: Is that it?
[SPEAKER_00]: That's it.
[SPEAKER_00]: All right.
[SPEAKER_00]: We'll be right in.